what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to i
don't have a name for this segment but
i'm gonna call it interviewing people i
know
[Laughter]
[Music]
ipk so um today i have a special guest
and for those of you that don't know
donovan has been a huge support for the
channel when i was up and coming i was
so close to quitting and donovan was a
huge support system in helping me figure
out equipment and helping me just with
like youtube in general so the one the
only donovan sharp hello
hey how you doing
and devon
hello how are you how are you doing
pearl i'm good how are you i'm awesome
so guys for those of you that may or may
not know when i was coming up
i did red pill reactions and donovan
was one of the people that i reacted to
yes
so donovan why don't you tell them how
we met
oh my god so um
you know this is interesting i don't
really remember if it was you who
reached out to me
or if it was me who who reached out to
you but i remember
someone sent me i had i had done the um
uh i talked about the reasons why
the the white girls on the bachelor
were going to be uh ostracized from the
quote unquote white community so
basically what i said is that white
women who who publicly date black men
take themselves out of the running to be
with white men now hindsight being 2020
i can see now that it's not as much of a
thing as it used to because it used to
be a huge thing
but
because i think people are a little bit
more quote unquote progressive but
there's still that stigma there are a
lot of white guys whether they admit it
or not they will not date white women
who have been known to commingle with
brothers and so
you reacted to you reacted to that
assertion and it was one of uh and one
of uh i guess one of my followers let me
know they're like hey you know just
pearly things or this girl pearl uh out
in the uk did a reaction to your video
and so it was so your reaction was so
funny
it was like it was it was it was so
funny i did a reaction
of your reaction to my reaction and
that's i think that's when you reached
out to me and uh at that point we were
like okay yeah hey you know what let's
get together let's talk it out and we
ended up finding common ground and all
that good stuff so yeah and then you
brought devon on that stream too because
i was so that was before devon was
really on your platform so i was so
curious about like what devin was like
yeah that conversation between uh uh you
and dev that essentially stole the show
um that was very interesting because
you're like wait a minute is devon there
i want to talk to her what is this what
is it you know this mythical creature
whatever the case may be but uh that was
that was all a good fight yeah that was
when i was screening calls i think and
you guys let me jump on oh yeah that's
exactly what that was yep yep yeah and
so the reason back that i was so curious
about who devin was was because i had
never heard of a red pill like type of
relationship okay so um to start why
don't you tell for my audience that
doesn't know tell them what is red pill
content
okay the red pill is simple the red pill
is the ans the red pill is the solution
to feminism it's a combination of a
solution to feminism combined with the
way women really operate these days most
men grow up thinking that women operate
one way
but in actuality they operate another
way and even though there are countless
men who have experienced
these contradictions in terms of what
we're told versus what we see the vast
majority of men still either can't or
won't
uh
allow themselves to subscribe to the
fact that hey
these women are not they're not they're
not our grandmothers they're not
really not really our grandma they're
not our ancestors women operate now in a
certain way and the thing is pearl is
that women have men and women have
always been the same it's really the
environment that's changed women have
always been hypergamous there has women
have always been hope pergamos as well
it's just that now with the globalized
sexual marketplace and of course the
advent of the smartphone women now have
access to all the sausage they want and
their smartphones allow them to hide it
so again just to sort of wrap things up
the red pill and red pill content is
just telling guys hey this is what
you're told we're going to tell you guys
what you've been told is a lie this is
this is the truth this is how this is
the solution to feminism that's really
all it is so can i have an example of
something that is blue pill and how you
would fix it with red pill
yeah so for example um a lot of guys
there are
dead bedrooms a lot of men um
they um they say oh you know i've i'm
married and i haven't had sex with my
wife in three months
that is a quote unquote blue pill
relationship now if the if the man is
not upholding his end of the bargain
let's say he lost his job he got fat um
he stopped caring he's you know gambling
and all that good stuff okay that's fine
i understand that interestingly enough
those kinds of men tend to have the most
success with modern women but taking it
back to what we're talking about now is
if you're a man and you're not upholding
you're into the bargain then you don't
deserve a woman to be right or die for
you but
in most cases as far as relationships
and marriages are concerned the man is
upholding his end of the bargain he's
the he is the breadwinner he takes care
of the kids he's good to his wife he
doesn't he doesn't he doesn't run around
on his wife a lot of people think that's
a bad thing to do but in return they're
not being rewarded for their loyalty
towards their women they're actually
being punished and so the
so the red pill solution to that is
number one
make sure you select a woman who is on
your program and number two make sure
you keep your value high no that doesn't
guarantee anything you can keep your
value high and do everything the red
pill the right way and the [ __ ] can
still go wrong women can and will leave
you for any reason or no reason at all
at any time that's just that's just how
it is there are no guarantees in life
but the red pill seeks to increase the
odds of success with women without them
taking your pound of flesh
and tell me do you think that feminism
is contributing to the crazy high
standards that we see from women today
oh yeah of course of course um and look
women can have women can have high
standards
people are entitled to having whatever
standards they want unless you're 300
pounds
listen if you're 300 if you're a 300
pound woman and you want a man with a
six-pack abs a six-foot dick and you
know a six-car garage who's making six
figures fine if that's what you want
that's cool
is it likely that you're going to get
that as a 300-pound woman no it's
possible but highly unlikely so and and
feminism
has told women that they can have it all
feminism has told women if you act like
a man you will get the man of your
dreams if you're a boss babe uh if you
get your degree if you make a lot of
money you're going to get the man of
your dreams the 666 guy um but women
even though there is so much empirical
data so many
anecdotes from around the world
people can see that it's not working but
they're still they still have these
ridiculous standards so that's where we
are right now
okay so then my next question is
how
do you have a red pill relationship what
is the difference between a relationship
that is red pilled and one that is you
know like the traditional i don't even
want to say traditional like a modern
relationship
um i'll let deb go first on this
i'll go i'll go first and then and then
i'll let you oh i'll let you go first
and then i'll then then i'll go after
you
i don't want to i don't want to suck the
air out of the room
you stuck there
no i mean i have no idea what you're
talking about
um let's see i think our relationship is
um
is different because there are
there are set
expectations there are set boundaries
and there are
uh there's a mutual respect as far as
what our roles are in this relationship
um
you know you know
what what brought me to the red pill was
that was learning that the the narrative
that we're taught
um doesn't match the reality so like the
whole happy wife happy life type of
thing you know and prioritizing the
women's happiness over the happiness of
men it it doesn't equate to a happy
relationship in the long run um better
it's to be said um like happy spouse
happy house where you know both people
are are are benefiting from their
relationship and you know are are happy
you know it's really all anybody wants
us to be happy
so um
for calling this a red pill relationship
i would say
um
we both stay in our lane
we don't try to take over one another's
role one another's job um we communicate
effectively uh we
respect one another to the point where
okay you know if i trust that he's gonna
say what he's gonna do
and he's trusting that i'm doing what
i'm saying and not only that i have i
offer the proof to back it up um so what
we one of the things that i think sets
us apart from other couples is that we
uh we close the the margin for cheating
um which is
something that a lot of couples just
either choose not to pay attention to
or we just accept this thing as normal
um you know girls you know
taken women being uh on social media
posting as if they don't have a marriage
or a relationship to protect
um you have women going to you know
going out girls nights out doing vegas
trips acting like they're single when
really they have a family at home that
they need to protect women aren't really
being held that well let me put it this
way
women have this entitlement that they
they expect they deserve the best they
want the best um and it's it's the world
is their oyster but they lack any
accountability as to
how
why what when where it's just the
magically be manifested um if we if we
benefit if we if we think about it it
will happen if we wish for it it'll come
true
um no relationships take a lot of work
and uh to have a a healthy one to have a
happy one where both people are as
equally happy you really need to put in
the groundwork early and i think that's
one thing that set us apart for most
relationships oh yeah we didn't just
come together and then figure it out
over time he knew what he wanted out of
things i knew what
didn't work put it that way and i was
looking for guidance and saying hey
what we've been told it doesn't work
so i obviously need to find someone who
i can follow their lead and who is going
to show me a different way that could
ultimately lead to happiness and we've
been five years strong at this point and
can you talk a little bit more about why
girls nights out are disrespectful
because just devil's advocate here i
mean it's not like you're going to hook
up you're just going to have a good time
with your girls
yeah you which obviously leads to
drinking
um it leads to interacting with men you
don't know
um it leads to making poor decisions um
you know
if you're out there dancing with your
friends yeah you could just be dancing
with your friends next time you know
you've got a strange guy who's bumping
up behind you you know and let's just
take a flash moment of any of these
scenes of these girls nights out and
just like just take a picture of it and
if your husband saw that or your
significant other saw that what would
they think
and a lot of women don't think about
how they look and how they're presenting
themselves to the world and if you
present yourself to the world as a
single person the world will treat you
as such or they don't care right
yeah a lot of times they just don't care
good
no
yep do you think so one observation that
i've had is i think a lot of times girls
act like this because they married their
second choice oh yeah
do you feel like that's something that
you've seen
oh yeah 100 man um
the difference between and it's weird
because a lot of women marry who they
believe is their first choice and then
over the years their first choice
becomes their second choice so they
marry the guy they think is the highest
value guy out there but then they are
handpicked by these men these husbands
are handpicked by their wives they're
hand-picked by movies television
commercials netflix etc etc and then
when guys like me come out and say hey
listen don't be afraid to don't be
afraid to raise your voice to your woman
oh my god that's misogynistic and
borderline illegal and blah blah blah
then when i tell people listen man i
don't commit i do not commit to women
who go to clubs or bars oh my god it's
just for girls nights out
okay that's fine but what what this what
this really comes down to is the reason
why these men turn into their wives
their their wives second and sometimes
even third choice depending upon the
number of times they cheat is because
men are
illegally castrated we we are
our society shames a man's ability and
instinct to protect a woman from herself
to protect his relationship there's no
reason a man should be okay with his
wife or his girlfriend going to bars or
clubs even if nothing happens the fact
of the matter is is that bars and clubs
putting yourself or a woman a lot of
people say if a woman doesn't if a woman
loves you she will not cheat that's
incorrect if a woman loves you she will
never put herself in position to cheat
she will never put herself in an
environment where infidelity is uh
uh can happen more times than not social
media is a breeding ground for
infidelity bars clubs traveling alone
girls nights out girls trips and there
are so many women i don't know what the
percentages are but there's enough women
who use these extracurricular activities
that put their relationships at risk as
a ruse for just going out to have fun
when in actuality they really want it
they really just want to hook up with
other guys there's nothing wrong with
women hooking up with a bunch of dudes
there's nothing wrong with that a lot of
guys say oh my god women are terrible
because i want to sleep around listen
man i've known a lot of promiscuous
females and most of them are actually
pretty cool
there are some that i really could not
stand but a lot of promiscuous women are
not bad people they're bad girlfriends
and wives but that does not make them
bad people i think we need to really i
think we need to really understand that
the the sexual marketplace is devoid of
morality and it should be because
because when we're talking about natural
selection
we as humans we're we're the only
species on earth who appear to have the
the the ability to reason on 30
different levels we get emotional when
we get cheated on we get emotional when
things happen lions and lionesses don't
get emotional when they see you know
simba smash and nala then smashing
another female line it just doesn't it
just doesn't work that way um and so i
think that i think a lot of men the
reason why they end up being the second
choice of their wives is because they
end up sort of bending the knee to the
almighty society oh my god i can't
believe you did x y and z men these days
are literally discouraged from their
they're discouraged from protecting
their relationships and that's why most
of them end in divorce and or infidelity
that's right like emasculation is not
only normalized it's encouraged oh yes i
mean people just see it as it's funny
you know yeah and then on the the flip
side it's like to recognize his
masculinity to appreciate his
masculinity to to understand and respect
his boundaries then that's seen as as as
him being toxic and controlling so it's
okay
if we
try to if we publicly humiliate our men
um and disrespect them on the regular
whether we're ordering at a restaurant
or talking to our friends
um and just to say oh my god he can't
even make an egg you know like okay
there are jokes and then there is the
point to which you have you
have
characterized your husband as so useless
that now you believe it
um and so a lot of women end up taking
on these oh well i can't trust him to do
this he can't do that so let me take
over let me take over i if somebody's
got to do it and the next thing you know
you're you describe your husband and
your brain as useless
and the truth is that you've just butted
him out of your entire relationship
well and a lot of girls don't realize
that the nagging is so deep like that's
men men love their respect right and
when you're just like that's how they
feel love and when you're disrespecting
a man that's that's saying you don't
love him basically
yes literally
a woman can't love a man she doesn't
respect and it it's it's weird because
when men and women are seeing their
wedding vows or when they're committing
to each other whatever the case may be
there are back in the day
just about every woman fully intended on
going through with their wedding vows
but these days it could not be more
different it's really just kind of lip
service just to kind of say what you
want to say and now we have people
rewriting their vows and
and the uh whoever is in charge of the
uh of the wedding
he sits there for 10 minutes and talks
about everything that the man needs to
do for her
that the husband needs to do for the
wife but then when it comes to the
wife's responsibility
now it's crickets that's that's just how
it is these days well and that's why you
see everyone asking women what they
bring to the table and it's crickets
yeah right right
it's interesting what the the question
what do you bring to the table should be
extended what can you offer me
that you have never given to another man
most women can't most women can't answer
that question because most women have
given their bodies to men they've given
them their time they've given them
children they've given they've given all
of these other men all of these things
but then they expect a man to give them
everything that we have to offer i think
we heard this on the sauce cast um it's
um it's meat it's uh what is it money
energy attention and time
when
women expect all of this money uh energy
attention and time for for what what for
them just being there no no no you've
given what what you are offering to me
is something that you've given to 474
other dudes no i need to know what you
bring i need it 474.
dude i'm trying to tell you
420.
it might have been for it might have
been
403 listen whatever the case may be
there are some triple and quadruple
digit hoes out here running these
streets and we will never listen you
will never know what help most women
probably don't even know what their body
counts are but the point is is that dude
99 of women out there don't bring
anything to the table that they haven't
brought to the table and every other
relationship which is pta and i'm not
talking about the parent teachers yeah i
mean this is where um
this is where being average at best
comes to your advantage because you've
got to like have some utility you got to
bring something useful to the table
because it ain't looks you know
well and that's well this is this is
what this is what that what this is what
devin's talking about devon's the most
attractive woman i've ever committed to
she's certainly the most useful i've had
some listen man i've been with dated
slept with some extremely attractive
women uh in my day and listen some of
them i like some of them i thought i
loved but in the end
uh good-looking women
are useless because they've never really
had to be useful especially in this day
and age most sevens eights nines and
tens are monetized or sponsored in some
type of way that's not a slight on them
that's just the world we live in well as
an attractive woman if you are given the
world simply because of the way you look
what motivation is there to develop
yourself outside of the way that you
look as a result we have some extremely
uh hollow vapid good-looking women out
here who don't really bring much to the
table except for good looks and drama
and a lot of guys a lot of guys would
kill for good looks and drama for a
little while but as a man who has had a
lot of experience with a lot of
beautiful women and i'm glad that i i'm
glad i had that experience i wouldn't
trade it for the world and i would never
say well i would never no i'm glad that
i [ __ ] a bunch of hot [ __ ] the
private same token the the more the the
you quickly sort of figure out that the
more attractive a woman is the less
useful they tend to be um and people can
say oh well that's your excuse listen
man um say whatever you want i'm i'm
happy in my relationship i tell guys all
the time if you're looking for if you're
looking for a long-term relationship or
someone to commit to
dudes eights nine dudes sevens eights
nines and tens belong to the game man
look look at the five to six range um
look for a girl who's who's in the five
to six range who becomes maybe a seven
or an eight behind closed doors
so question what
devin what was your biggest challenge
when i'm assuming your past
relationships may have been more modern
is that true or false
may have been more what modern
i'm assuming this is the most
traditional relationship you've been and
i can't imagine like i i mean yeah if
you want to put a label on it yeah i
mean
my my previous relationship where i was
married for
15 we were together almost 20 years
so
you know i didn't i didn't know that
there was like
a way to do this you know i thought the
way that they teach you is the way that
it goes and
you know you go through life and and you
you you know you don't cheat and you
try to make it work right and it's a
little bit more complicated than that um
i think that people overlook the
importance of respect in a relationship
because i don't think that women are
capable of loving a man that they do not
respect
and
women actually
lose respect for their men by the way
that they treat them
so finding a man who won't put up with
any of the nonsense won't put up with
the wrong tone of voice won't put up
with you know me being disrespectful in
any way
makes forces me into the position where
i say okay you know
uh that's not you know that doesn't fly
that doesn't become a habit and you know
we
we we're consistent with one another
um a lot of people don't have
consistency in their relationships
they're oh no they're what girl the girl
is as as sweet one day and she said
she's a total you know what the next day
and
you know the the man just takes it
so
good
so i was just curious it was there a
learning curve
that's what i was curious about yeah i
had a lot of bad habits that that had to
be
almost literally like trained out of me
it was like you know you know similar to
the things like i said like tone of
voice but even something like as simple
as when we're in the car and he's
driving
and
you know it's the you know to say okay
hey we need to turn left here or like no
no no backstage driver you know yeah
like trying to you know
trying to be just being an annoying
passenger basically you know
you
anytime
like for example
donovan loves to leave like all of the
cabinet doors open whenever he goes in
the kitchen like everything's open like
the microwave's open the freezer i'll do
that too
yeah
what do you want yeah
you know the old me would have been like
god you're so lazy like you just closed
or like to make a make a point i'll slam
them shut or something oh hell no or you
know like god do you mind like what's
wrong with you now i'm just like you
know what
let's let's take a step back and think
about the grand scheme of things okay
um
he provides
he protects
he you know he makes me laugh like we
have we have a great life together if
if all it takes is for me to close a
couple cabinet doors every now and then
maybe i should just shut my mouth and do
it uh we need to really pick our battles
and a lot of women don't know how to to
do that um small potatoes are small
potatoes these are things that you got
to learn to live with and you you know
like
the small things that people do that
like women just oh my god i can't stand
he leaves a toilet seat up that oh my
god that's a deal breaker oh my god you
know like hey you're gonna be alone for
a very long time if you don't learn how
to live with somebody and i think a lot
of people don't know how to
um how to uh moderate what they're
willing to accept um some women just end
up accepting things that are extremely
bad and won't accept a toilet seat up
but they'll accept you know him being an
alcoholic yeah something like that so
yeah
women have a little it's a little
convoluted well it's convoluted because
women
women are under the impression the
reason why women are so picky and
selective and women have to be the more
selective gender this is just how it is
there are biological reasons involved
i'm not going to get into that but women
have become so selective
that they it's almost like they take
themselves off the market they are so
inundated with option with what they
perceive to be long-term options day in
day out that they disqualify men for the
most idiosyncratic things just like just
like dev just said leaving the the the
toilet seat up dude in all the years
i've ever known deb i leave the toilet
seat up all the time she has never ever
ever said anything about it i leave
cabinets open all the time she doesn't
she never has bitched and moaned about
it and the reason for that is because
the life that i provide for her makes
those things
menial it doesn't it doesn't really
matter
but but women are always so picky and
they disqualify men for the smallest of
uh the smallest of infractions only
because they think they've got a line of
men
waiting to make their acquaintance while
that may be true these men are
interested only in short-term uh
short-term relationships in other words
they're only really after them for sex
and the men that want them for more than
just sex are not the men they want
unfortunately for women they don't
figure this out until they're in their
mid to late 30s and they've been dumped
for the third time in three days
in three days
okay so if a man is watching this right
and he's saying you know what i want my
girl to be red pill this is the type of
relationship that i want what are the
steps
towards
achieving that
yeah first off you got to be red-pilled
yourself man um you have to
you have to really know what you're
doing fortunately for men
um our sexual our sexual market value um
declines at a much lower rate than a
woman's that's the first thing um the
second thing that men have to understand
is that you have to know this stuff
inside and out
there's no reciting lines what men have
to understand is that red pill
relationships are very different from
the pickup artist thing this pickup
artist scene if the pickup artist game
and the nagging and all that stuff if
that works on a woman then you're with
the wrong woman game quote-unquote
pick-up game that's for broken women
that's just all there is to it now are
the elements of pickup game that men can
incorporate in their relationships
absolutely taking the lead uh calling
her out on her [ __ ] having a
no-nonsense attitude having some sort of
direction the difference is is when
you're in a red pill relationship this
is actually who you are whereas in the
pua community you're acting like someone
who is red pill through and through now
there are some men that are red pilled
and are in the pickup scene and they're
going to be players for life but most
men are not
most men don't want to be players for
life most men most women want to be in
relationship so i think the first couple
of steps you have to be red pilled
number one uh and number two you have to
know what you're doing number three and
i can do i can talk about this all day
but i'm gonna make this very succinct
number three you have to be you got to
be willing to walk away there's so many
men men have to stop
fast forwarding their interactions with
women they see a pretty girl she shows a
little bit of interest they go on a
couple of dates all of a sudden now
you're thinking about being in a
relationship with this woman you're
thinking about children you're thinking
about marriage which is a big mistake
here in the west you're thinking about i
do that
yeah well you will find your thing well
that's the thing listen you're a woman
and that's what you're supposed to do
you date sorry what are we getting
married yes exactly but we as men we
can't operate that way otherwise we end
up getting finessed what men have to do
what men have to end up doing is okay i
like this person but we need to reserve
judgment uh after four seasons you know
nothing about a woman after after the
first date you know nothing about a
woman after six months if you want to
know who a woman really is vet her for
at least a year and then you'll find out
i can't hear you lala
no no i'm just sorry
so vet her for at least a year so the
first step is that they need to study
red pill content so they could do that
by watching your videos
of course yeah fresh and fit yeah read
the rational mail etc yeah yeah yeah so
that's that's step one step two is not
just assuming that
like you have to vet the women for about
a year how when they're starting how do
they establish frame in a relationship
so that they're leading and she isn't
different men over and over and over
again they start to believe it um when
she's talking about her ex and how
terrible he was and they were together
for 15 years right don't fall for it she
was she did something too
um
i think a lot of guys need to also look
at when they're when they're vetting
women to look at their look at her
relationship with her family
um
does she have a father father figure in
her life um are her parents still
together like does she have a functional
relationship that she can model uh uh
her own after um i think that's really
important and something that's very
lacking today it's not always a
prerequisite to find but it's it's very
useful um to find a woman who has a
a strong
family structure good family structure
um also like the length of her previous
relationships is also another indicator
does she know how to keep a man
a lot of women these days do not they
know how to get them they because
today's currency is validation and
attention that's right and you know
pretty girls are rich when it comes to
that so
um if
they're just kind of oh i've been dating
on and off for like i've been like you
know i've just been seeing people for
the last three years
that just means they're sleeping i've
only had like one boyfriend in the past
like five years which means like she's
been sleeping around for five years yeah
yeah so um and as for for for women and
i guess this is a clue for men as well
to find a woman who
might be open to a more traditional or
red pill type of relationship
is she willing to invest in the
relationship first that's right is she
willing to put aside her time her energy
not necessarily money you don't need a
lot of money to do it to do this but is
she willing to show you that she's
paying attention to your not only just
your needs but your wants um you know
does she she listen when you talk
you know
um and is she willing to say hey you
know and if he takes her out to dinner
on a date her next move should be to
offer to make him dinner uh you know at
her place or his place you know whatever
um
there you know just oh if he likes
something
invest in it buy tickets for it you know
you know donovan likes nascar you know
so i like all racing one thing i did
first birthday is i bought him at nascar
experience so that next time we're next
to a race we can go drive over nascar
all right
and they're just like little things that
you can do
that show a man oh my gosh she might be
a little bit different because i'm not
pulling teeth here and she's actually
paying attention and she's investing
and
you know what remember when freshman fit
when the girl was like clean your spot
oh my god yeah you have a girl over and
she's just laying around making a mess
probably not the type of woman that you
want to
spend you know more than just some fun
with um if she's there she she wants to
take care of you take care of your place
those are nurturing qualities of a
quality woman
so so first up he finds the red pill
then he learns red pill then next step
is vetting the girl and making sure that
she's investing equally or so i mean
obviously relationships are never equal
but
she's she is putting time and attention
maybe she cleans his apartment buys him
tickets whatever
yeah she lets him know what she's up to
how does he get her on his program
yeah he's uh he's got to be he's got to
have a program number one
uh and number two he has to make it he
has to make it very clear to her early
on that she is going to help him with
his program i remember dude i think it
was what three or four months in
uh to dev and i talking she built my she
built the the first version of my
website all right what
yeah
of a you guys
than she built she built the she built
the website
a month before that she bought and paid
for the entire vac for our entire hawaii
vacation eight thousand dollar trip she
footed the she footed the and the the
entire bill
were you were you nervous at all because
you weren't dating right
we were more talking
yeah so yeah we weren't i mean we
weren't dating we were right yeah we're
i mean we were listen we were sleeping
together and that was pretty much it
yeah so at that point there was no
commitment what do you say to girls that
say you can't do too much for a man
before you have the commitment
i'll actually answer that um
a lot of women
want and this is this is such a huge
women make so many mistakes when it
comes to relationships but one of the
biggest mistakes that women make is not
understanding that they have to audition
for the part women tell well i'm not
going to give him girlfriend benefits
until he makes me my girlfriend well a
guy like me who has options i'm not
going to give you the title of
girlfriend until you can prove that you
can be a girlfriend i'm not going to
give him long-term relationship benefits
without him giving me the long-term
relationship commitment there are more
of you than there are of me so it is on
you to qualify to me
so so at the end of the day women want a
women want to be awarded a part that
they have neither auditioned for nor can
prove that they can play it uh a famous
play i don't know uh the sound of music
right uh i don't know what the the the
main characters female lead they did not
give that lead to uh they didn't give
that lead i think it might have been
julie andrews in the movie they didn't
give that lead to a woman oh you know
what i think i should play the main
character okay well you have to watch no
no no no no you need to give me the part
no that is literally women expecting
long-term relationship benefits before
they're actually committed to that's
like that's like someone demanding a
part in a play that they have not
auditioned for look if you want the
title you need to audition for the title
if i can't see a willingness for you to
audition and then the ability to be with
a guy like me then guess what it's going
to remain strictly casual that's just
all there is to it and it's it's funny
women get into
situation chips or entanglements with a
with with guys all the time then they
meet one they really like six seven
eight months down the line they think
well why hasn't eric committed to me
because you have you think that you're
entitled to his commitment you haven't
shown him any sign you haven't shown him
any sign that you want to be in a
relationship other than flapping at the
gums hey i want a relationship action
speak louder than words don't tell him
you want to be in a relationship show
him because he needs to see that you are
equal to the task because if all you're
doing is yapping at the gums we always
say well i guess she's all talking no
show that's why he keeps banging you and
not committing yeah it is a chicken in
the egg or a chicken and egg argument um
there's a common trope that i say is
like why buy the cat why buy the milk if
the cow is free no why buy the cow
for free yeah it's why buy the cow we
can get the milk for free
no no no no not for sale no why buy the
cow why do we have to buy the cow see we
get the cow to get the milk right
why buy the cow if you can get the milk
for free basic but basically why commit
to a woman when you can just get the sex
without the commitment that's what it is
that's what really what guys say go
ahead continue without please well the
way i had it figured it made sense now
it doesn't so never mind
i was gonna say man taking care of a cow
is unsure well no but your point is well
founded because taking care of a woman
is a chore but why but here's the thing
women or
women or cows the most valuable ass the
most valuable thing a cow has to offer
is milk right
and so if a man has to buy the cow in
order to get the milk then he is going
to buy the cow back in the day if you
wanted to have sex with a woman you
needed to be married to her well guess
what the advent of feminism a hormonal
birth control roe v wade
women are cows now well no now
the point is is that women are giving
away the milk without requiring men to
buy the cow they're giving away their
bodies without requiring commitment and
so guys are like wait a minute you mean
i don't have to be in a committed
relationship to have sex girls are just
giving it away without any sort of
commitment great and then these women on
the back end wonder why guys don't want
to commit to them because you are giving
them the commitment benefits without
actually requiring the commitment that's
why we got these always running around
um so
[Music]
sorry sorry
[Music]
okay so um
the the next step so first she has to
make sure she's put in the effort she's
putting in the commitment are there [ __ ]
tests that women commonly do early i've
heard this term and i don't think i
don't know if it's
if women [ __ ] tests like on purpose
because some of the stuff that i hear
guys talk about that are [ __ ] tests i
think they're kind of
on accident to us
it's not on accident it's the way you
guys are designed [ __ ] tests
[ __ ] tests vary depending on the
situation if you're at a bar or club
trying to pick up a woman women [ __ ]
test you on purpose i don't date black
guys answer oh neither do i i mean can
you imagine
dude i get a laugh at that i get a laugh
at that every time
um
when women [ __ ] test you in that social
pua scenario they just want to make sure
that you have experience with women
women in relationships [ __ ] tests on
[ __ ] test on autopilot this is not a bad
thing women have to [ __ ] test what women
are doing here is they're biting the
gold and women have to [ __ ] test their
men every so often to make sure that he
is still the man that that that she fell
in love with um so in relationships
women [ __ ] test on autopilot now there's
a big difference between [ __ ] tests and
disrespect if a [ __ ] if a supposed [ __ ]
test makes you feel upset or angry
that's not a [ __ ] test that's disrespect
but for men to not expect a woman a
woman who doesn't test a man is not
interested in a man you can walk up to a
girl and start chatting her up and blah
blah blah blah oh man she hasn't tested
me then you go in for the number close
and she tells you well i have a
boyfriend or well blah blah blah and
you're like what the hell she never [ __ ]
tested you because she never was
interested in you in the first place
women
women will [ __ ] test men as a in
relationships women will indirectly [ __ ]
test men as a matter of
reconfirmation rather than
disqualification now there are
impassable [ __ ] tests at which point
your woman has already lost respect for
you the the relationship is likely going
to be over but [ __ ] tests are a good
thing if your woman if your woman is not
[ __ ] testing you in a relationship it
means one of two things either number
one you're doing it right and you don't
give her a reason to [ __ ] test you or
number two she just needs to she needs
to pinch herself a little bit and kind
of put a and and and just make sure okay
is this the guy that i'm meant to be
with is this guy the same
and can i have a couple examples of a
[ __ ] test that you should break up with
a girl over and a [ __ ] test that this is
how you would handle it
a breakup with a girl over in a
long-term or short-term relationship
let's say long-term because i think a
lot of my audience is looking for wives
more than short-term relationships if
they want pick up they've got a
relationship
yeah they've got to go to different
channels that would wow that's that's a
very good question
um what is the kind of [ __ ] test if i
were to get a [ __ ] test
well here's the thing a [ __ ] test is
just that it's a test if a [ __ ] test
leads to a breakup in a man's mind then
chances are either you were too weak to
pass the [ __ ] test and just didn't have
it in you or what she did was disrespect
so a lot of girls think that mentioning
hey my ex texted me today they think
that's a [ __ ] test that is not a [ __ ]
test that is disrespect if
now before the relationship you make it
clear listen i don't commit to women who
stay in contact with people who have
been inside of them so the minute she
tells you hey my text exited me my ex my
text next to me my ex texted me and i
responded and they've been going back
and forth well guess what she just she
just broke up with you because she
engaged in a behavior that makes her a
kind of woman that you don't date uh so
that's the kind of quote-unquote [ __ ]
test that will end the relationship her
putting herself her wanting to put your
relationship your supposed relationship
at risk and telling you about it that's
not a [ __ ] test that's disrespect yeah
that was my um
thought as well was if she's like hey
i'm going to i'm going out to lunch with
so-and-so from work male co-worker
um
[Music]
that's just not a [ __ ] test yeah
uh
ignore what your feelings are
and that's that's that is important um
when you start operating without the
consideration of the person that you
supposedly love your relationship is
over
and that's what you guys do in a lot of
your skits right you'll go through
different scenarios that maybe some men
used to put up with or that's a
situation that they've been in and and
your message is you don't have to accept
this you can walk away you don't have to
put women on a pedestal
right i think what most men and most men
especially in the west they have no idea
just how much more valuable they are
as people than the women they are
pursuing just because dude listen man i
have known some extremely beautiful
women who are extremely low value people
yeah they're cool and they're cool to
hang out with and do drugs with and all
and all this other kind of stuff
but they don't have a pot to piss in
they're crass they act like men
a lot of them dropped out of high school
they're just they're just trash people
um and and and it's funny it's it the
more attractive a woman is i'm trying to
tell you i've been through i've been
through enough attractive women to know
and understand this to be 100 true the
more attractive a woman is the less
valuable she tends to be the more of an
attitude she tends to have the more
entitled she tends to be the more she
tends to nag because attractive women
get the benefit of the doubt and
attractive women live the attractive
women in the united states and the west
they live the best lives of any class of
human on the planet regardless of their
behavior that's just how this is amber
hurt is really the first attractive
woman who has ever been taken to task
over the [ __ ] behavior that she put
a man through only because she tried the
okie doke on him but if you're expecting
an attractive woman to just fall in line
because
you think she's a good person because
she's attractive you're gonna have
another thing coming
there's a comment that said should a
woman have any male friends
she can have listen should a woman have
any male friends in terms of what a
relationship yeah in a relationship
i mean a woman is entitled to see what i
guess but what he needs to i guess the
question really is should i accept the
fact that my long-term girlfriend has
male friends the answer is no you should
not accept that the only exceptions are
if her male friend is gay um
her hair no seriously one of her one of
her hairdressers his name was travis
dude coolest dude coolest guy in the
world if devin wanted to go and hang out
with him and all that listen go knock
yourself out um but that's the only
exception um male friends are um male
friends now here's the thing you cannot
tell your woman what she can or cannot
do you can't do that you can't control
women nor should you seek to control
them but what you can do is you can
control your behavior so when guys ask
well is having male friends acceptable
well only if you accept it if you make
yourself scarce if you let your woman
know through your words and actions hey
look if you have male friends that's
cool we're just going to keep it casual
if we're in a committed relationship and
all of a sudden you start befriending
males guess what it's going to it's
going to devolve from a long-term
relationship to
uh uh to something casual that's all
there is to it you don't have to [ __ ]
you don't have to fight you don't have
to argue if she engages in activities
that put your relationship at risk just
downgrade the relationship no problem at
all
and so that's why it's so important to
have that up front your expectations
right
yeah absolutely and do you think a lot
of guys are afraid to say that up front
because of things like feminism and like
the
modern of course
i mean like back when back when i
actually read the comments and in the
chat and all that you see women anytime
i mention anytime i mentioned that you
know you have to protect a woman from
herself oh my god you're toxic and this
and that the third guys see this stuff
and so when they get into relationships
of their own or interactions with women
on their own
they're like well i don't want to be
toxic i don't want to be insecure i
don't want to be i don't want to be
jealous i don't want to be you know
considered to be one of these possessive
boyfriends so that that really sort of
nips that in the bud never be afraid as
a man to set boundaries if if she does
not allow you to set boundaries
dude no sweat off your back simply
downgrade the relationship to casual or
just a one-time fling and keep it moving
that's all you got to do you can't
control women man can't do it
and what i like about you too is you
also put a lot of accountability on men
you you don't just hold women
accountable you hold men accountable too
what are the common complaints you hear
from women about men and how can men
improve in their relationships
uh good god that's a well i don't really
get too many complaints uh about
sorry about valid complaints
oh valid complaints yeah yes um i don't
know
women complain about everything what are
what are some of the most common
complaints about men i mean i don't know
i suppose uh you know you hear this
stuff men ain't [ __ ] they're broke uh
they're cheaters blah blah blah blah i
mean i think that uh
women like to complain when men try to
move the goal posts on them
so they're they enter into i don't care
if it's a casual relationship or a
relationship they're whatever they're
dating their friends with benefits
whatever
but
all of a sudden he's willing to accept
ex behavior but then as time goes on
you can't say okay that was okay before
but that's not my pain now that's
exactly right um so it's really
important to to set those set your
boundaries set your expectations
enlighten her on your standards you know
over time don't just go on your first
date and be like i don't do this and i
don't do that absolutely you know it's
just it's a slow reveal
and as the slow reveal happens whether
she's going to accept that or not that's
fine but
you know how to categorize her but she
can never say oh well you didn't tell me
that i couldn't have male friends oh you
didn't tell me that you didn't you know
you didn't
you weren't okay with me doing girls
nights out um if if early in the
relationship it comes up and say yeah i
personally don't feel that committed
women you know women that i commit to
she should be doing that well then she
knows ahead of time but you can't you
can't just say it's okay one day and
then all of a sudden she wants
commitment and then you all of a sudden
drop a bunch of rules on her i think
that's going to be okay well here's
here's here's why this is not okay
it's because men are angling for
relationships first
as a man the biggest mistake you can
ever make in any interaction with women
is to angle for commitment first i'll
give you an example let's say pearl
let's say you found a car on let's just
say ebay you found a car for ten
thousand dollars right
you buy you you pay the ten thousand
dollars you get the car delivered to
your house and everything is cool you've
paid the money all the paperwork is done
except you don't have the title
let's let's let's then say a week later
the seller of the car the previous owner
says hey i know you paid the ten
thousand dollar asking price for the car
but for me to send you the title i'm
gonna need another five thousand dollars
you wouldn't pay that because it was
established in the beginning that in
order to possess what it was you wanted
you had to pay x amount of dollars which
was ten thousand dollars
this is the equivalent of angling for
commitment angling for commitment first
as a man and then laying the rules
the deal is this
when you ask a woman to be your
girlfriend you as a man are forfeiting
your you are forfeiting your right and
your ability to establish boundaries and
expectations because when you ask a
woman would you like to be my girlfriend
you are telling her directly actually
directly and indirectly that you have
now you have you have fulfilled all of
the requirements required to secure my
commitment
so a lot of so a lot of guys say hey
would you like to be my girlfriend
they're like oh yeah of course and girls
almost if if they really think they like
a guy if a girl if a guy asks her to be
oh yes of course she's going to say yes
because at that point she knows okay i
can take a deep breath now that i have
commitment
now now i can pretty much do whatever i
want
there you go and it's because it's
because he angled for relationship first
now a lot of guys might say well you're
the man you have to ask listen back in
the day that was true that is not true
today in 2022. in 2022 if you ask a
modern woman to be your girlfriend that
is a that that that is only going to
lead to a bad relationship because at
that point a woman looks looks at that
as a license to do whatever she wants
because you didn't establish boundaries
well donovan what if she never asks you
to be in a relationship then she doesn't
like you as much as you thought she did
at which point
at which point you continue to keep it
casual you can only you can only
establish boundaries when she angles for
a a relationship and i talk about this
all the time
women always say four or five months so
donovan what are we what are we what is
this this is their way of indirectly
asking you hey i want commitment
you need the very first or second time a
woman tries to angle for commitment you
need to put her off put her off put her
off she thinks she wants commitment
because either she really likes you or
she's tired of meeting your standards so
at that point you put her off a couple
times the third fourth time and if guys
have heard me say this all the time do
you want to know what it's like to be in
a relationship with with a guy like me
yes i really want to know okay unlock
your phone and hand it to me right now
okay dude 112 percent of women are like
oh my god i can't believe it blah blah
blah then they try to be slick and say
hey i'm ready to hand you my phone the
very next day not how it works honey
what that does is that shows her that in
order to be in a committed relationship
with me if you want my commitment you
are going to have to be 100 transparent
with me if i ask for your phone you give
it to me oh my god that's so insecure i
don't care what you call it that's a man
protecting himself because so many women
come into relationships being experts on
hiding their licentious [ __ ] behavior
they end up blindsiding guys out of
nowhere so it is incumbent upon men to
vet women thoroughly and establish from
the start if you want to be in a
relationship with a man like me this is
what's required so let's just say a
woman does pass this okay well i'm not
screwing anybody else here you go
okay well what about now well that's a
start oh my god what else do i have to
do funny you should ask
i'm not gonna tell you what you can or
can't do but i will tell you this
i don't commit to women who go to bars i
don't commit to women who go to clubs i
don't commit to women who stay in
contact with their ex i don't commit to
women who stay in contact with people
who've been inside them i don't commit
to women who travel alone i don't commit
to women on social media and on and on
and on and if it's just too much for her
to handle no problem don't get don't
take it personally she just doesn't like
you as much as you thought she did
there's no need to take it personally
like it is what it is maybe she's not
looking for something that serious but
then a lot of girls are like oh my god
that's too much and then i say okay well
let's say you were dating i don't know
chris hemsworth you're dating chris
hemsworth for six months and he says uh
by the way if you want to be in a
relationship with me i know this is a
bad australian accent i need you i need
access to your your telephone i need
access to your cameras
yeah yeah exactly do you see that yeah
dude everyone yes chris please listen
you can hire a partner
higher surveillance have me followed
i'll put a gps tracker in my coochie do
whatever you want and that's exactly the
point the reason why most women the
reason why all women would do that is
because of his value and that's exactly
the point your value dictates what a
woman is willing to what a woman is
willing to go through to secure your
commitment if you're not at the point
where you can start demanding these
things for women no problem we're men we
have time but do not sell yourself short
by angling for a relationship first with
women it dude it falls flat every single
time there are tons of men out there
whose wives and girlfriends do more for
their bosses or employers than they
would ever consider doing for their
husbands real talk
um so
ideally
when you're in a relationship with a
woman you want her
you want her to have you as her number
one right um as far as i'm willing to do
anything to make this work um and now
we're not talking about like sadistic
and abusive relationships we're talking
about healthy relationships that
requests have purposes to them um and
it's we're not just trying like
donovan's never asked me to do anything
that didn't have a purpose to it that
was just to see if i'd go ahead and do
it yeah i'm not dude man you know like
when we first started when we first like
started dating and we were getting
serious i went so far as to change my
phone number so anybody i talked to in
the past couldn't even get a hold of me
like i wanted a clean slate i wanted a
fresh start and i didn't want to have
any of those ghosts of the past
skeletons in the closet coming back to
haunt me um and and that was a way for
me to protect my new relationship with
this per with with donovan so
a lot of girls aren't willing to get off
social media they're not willing to
you know say okay my guy friends they're
great they had their time and purpose it
doesn't belong here you know if they get
if they hook up with somebody maybe we
could do a double d
you know you can still interact with
people but it's got to be on a
respectable level to where you're
putting your relationship first um and a
lot of people just don't value the fact
that relationships need to be protected
no and i've always said to guys that if
like i don't know if you've ever had a
girl that's like obsessed with you
that's what i always say to guys like
i'm sure you could think of one girl off
the top of your head that was just
something she would have did anything uh
yeah she was [ __ ] crazy well and i
always say you shouldn't settle for a
girl that's not that into you
okay it's a lot easier when they're
obsessed i mean there's lies you
shouldn't be like stuck in your house or
anything
well listen and it's funny when you say
obsessed you don't really mean obsessed
you just meet a woman who really really
likes you
and you have to have a woman who is
willing to
if if you want a woman if you want a
woman to really really make your life
better you need to have a woman who is
willing to do for you what she has never
done for any man i know that devin has
never done for any man well
i know that you don't know anything but
i'm willing to bet that it is far more
likely than not that devin has probably
never done for any man what she has done
for me i don't take anything for granted
including when it comes to my own woman
but that's really how a woman shows you
that she wants to be with you when she
is exhibiting behaviors that you know
she likely hasn't done in the past or
she's only done it with a few guys then
at that point you know she's really into
you
no i agree i think there's a lot of men
that women have just treated like crap
for a really long time and i think the
tides are turning i think men are
starting to wake up and realize they
don't have to accept this and i think
channels like yours are really important
because like you can he decodes you know
female nature in front of you in real
time and now he's giving you instead of
just talking about the problem they're
giving you a solution
yep yeah that's and you know what's
interesting every quote unquote red pill
content creator uh goes through we we
still go through the uh the red pill
phases
live and then living color when i first
came to youtube i was you know [ __ ]
ain't [ __ ] and three signs she's a [ __ ]
and four signs she belongs to the
streets and all that good stuff and it's
evolved i mean i started when i was what
uh this was back in 2014. um and i'm not
the world's greatest mathematician but
my content has evolved as i've evolved i
am dude my message has never ever
wavered it always stays the same the
delivery is is clearly different but the
message is always the same now
do i have some changes in opinion as far
as the operations within my red bull of
course of course you know with time
introspection things that you learn
along the way nobody has all of the
answers all at once i'm always learning
but i feel really good about where i'm
at in terms of my mindset
yeah no i think it's the same for women
when we find the red pill because at
first you're like
i mean you you saw some of my reactions
early where i'm just like
well there's this exact survey
but then you just start to realize like
like the red pill is talking about how
things generally are and how there's a
lot of big issues for men and it's not
maybe as individualistic because i think
women were sought what do they call it
solacism yeah solipsism
yeah they only think of things from
their point of view yeah
also there is someone in the comments
that wants to know how do you get your
woman to keep fit is it disrespectful to
ask
um how do you get your woman to keep we
have a personal trainer that comes to
the house five days a week
right but i mean not everybody not
everybody can afford that here's the
thing
um work out together right
no no man um if no no if you have to if
you have to
how can i put this if you have to
tell your woman hey you're you know
packing on the pounds blah blah blah
blah now don't get me wrong like devin
there have been times where devon's a
little puffier than normal at which
point i take action but devin's never
gotten fat she's never ever ever gotten
fat not on my goddamn watch i pay way
too much money for that but if if you're
with a woman who does not respect you
enough to take care of herself to remain
attractive to you this means she's not
that into you
and if she's not that into you there's
either something wrong with her
something wrong with you or both you
can't ever you can't talk a woman into
being in
into keeping herself in shape she has to
be motivated enough on her own to stay
in shape in order to stay in order to
stay uh to keep your commitment here's
another thing
you want to know how to keep your you
want to know how to get your woman to be
fit is number one you have to maintain
your value you don't have to be this
quote-unquote height you have to you
have to have high value right this
doesn't mean you have to be a
millionaire you have to be a good uh
steward of your money you've got to be
in above average shape you have to have
red pill awareness you have to know how
to handle women today's modern women as
they come if but that that's that of
course that's those are the
prerequisites but your woman has to know
and understand that if she doesn't
uphold her end of the bargain and keep
herself fit that you can and will
replace her if need be women don't
respond to hey baby i would really no
women respond to you flirting with the
hot waitress they respond to other women
looking at you your woman knows when
other women are looking at you and when
other women and the only way to get
other women to look at you is to stay in
shape
you know uh you know stay you know stay
fly dress nice smell nice etc etc if you
keep yourself in good shape then your
woman is going to keep her herself in
good shape because she sees how other
women are looking at you don't tell your
woman well listen you know i could
replace you nope show her and and there
might be and i don't i'm not i don't
look at the chat i've got that i've got
that all closed but there might be
people in the chat or the compass well
that's disrespectful
call it whatever you want that is what's
necessary in today's sexual and
relationship marketplace your woman has
absolutely got to know that you can and
will replace her if she gets fat so the
way to keep your woman from the the way
to keep your woman from gaining all that
weight in the first place is to make
sure that you keep your [ __ ] together
that's the best motivating factor
donovan donovan don't tell them that
that works
there's so many more lists like well it
shouldn't work that way 100 listen man
um
there are i'm there are a lot of a lot
of my critics and detractors talk about
my quote-unquote methods right it
shouldn't work this way you shouldn't do
this to your woman this is immoral there
blah blah blah i'm a hundred percent in
agreement with all of them but here's
the thing this is the world we live in
i'm not here talking about the way
things should be i'm here to talk about
the way things are
women and the the environment has
changed the environment has changed and
so women have changed with it
if you want to have successful if you
want to be successful women in 2022 you
have one of two options either deal with
them as they are or check out of the of
the dating market all together i'm not
going to be mad at you if you do one or
the other but wishing women were back in
the 1950s or bitching and moaning about
what's fair and what's not it you
shouldn't have to do that no i shouldn't
have to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] to get
respect from women but unfortunately
unfortunately that's what's required so
that's what we do men were solvers we
saw the problem okay women are hoes and
they're no they're they're no longer
exercising hypergamy but hoe pergamy and
if you're too nice to women they don't
respect you but if you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] they respect you more so guess
what we adjusted and surprise surprise
women are complaining about it and then
still [ __ ] us so this is what it is
men need to stop acting like victims in
their own relationship for their
lack of leadership
if your woman is getting overweight
um odds are she's bringing food into the
house that's not healthy
and if she's bringing food into the
house it's not healthy she's buying it
with the household budget which means if
it's your home that's you that's under
your control um there have been times
where donovan has been like okay i want
to review the grocery order or the
grocery list or whatever before you
submit it or before you bring it into
the house he's opened up the pantry and
just thrown out everything that he
didn't want to have in the house if it
was something that wasn't healthy um
there are there are ways that you can
express your uh
not just what you want but what your
requirements um and it's loud and clear
to the woman now if she's ignoring it if
she's you know just flat out district
going against your your requests um then
obviously there's there's a deeper issue
going on this relationship that's
further respecting periods
yeah that's what it is a lot of women
will try to hide their weight gain by
trying to fatten up their husbands as
well so if you're eating lasagna for
dinner three times a week
sounds wonderful no doesn't it
you know and she's she's baking and
she's baking chocolate cakes and all
this stuff
and it's great oh yeah my wife cooks and
she you know she dinners on the table
but it's it's unhealthy and it's making
you guys sick um odds are she's going
through something you all need to sit
down and figure it out um and you know
there are ways gentle ways that you can
encourage your significant other to work
out as far as hey let's go for a walk
let's do this no stop right there no no
no no no no no no no no no i gotta cut
you off no no no no this is bad advice
that listen love you to death sweetheart
this is bad advice
listen man yeah it has to be established
from the start i never have to tell dev
hey honey uh you want to go for a walk
no devin devin's ass is in there
sweating her ass off five days a week
because she knows if she doesn't she's
she's the [ __ ] up out of here and the
reason why she knows she's the [ __ ] up
out of here is because of who and what i
am i'm not special i'm not unique i'm
just i'm on
yes i'm i've i've slept with more
i've slept more women than the average
man yes i make far more than they ever
than than uh than the average man
and those are those are the things that
sort of encompass who i am but if devin
didn't feel like it was worth it then
she would not do it there is no reason
at all for you to ever have to tell your
woman hey i'm gonna get you an exercise
or gym membership by then it's already
too late if your woman does not respect
you enough to keep herself in shape to
maintain uh to maintain your attraction
to her it's over there is no let's go
for a walk there is no buying her a
peloton for christmas she's either gonna
stay in shape of her own accord or she's
not period that's that's what i was
gonna say my butt was him telling you
directly is is going to be the most
effective that's right
women can't take hints no women women
not only can women women can take hints
they just choose to ignore them
they do they they they choose to ignore
the hints and when it's funny when dev
and i first got together um
it's interesting because devin's always
had a really nice figure but we're not
getting any younger i tried to get her
to the gym and this and that and the
other so i said you know what i know one
thing devin's not gonna do she's not
gonna waste my money i hired her a
personal trainer it's made all the
difference in the world yes it is very
costly it is very expensive it is also
very worth it and i love it
well and what i realized is you know the
more i like heard about the the things
you you specifically said on your
channel i realized you're giving men a
solution to women that aren't
that aren't traditional anymore yep so
so that's right
and i realized that like being in the
west women just were not traditional
it's like
yeah they're modern women and what you
do is you come in and give modern
solutions well women
modern women want they want men to be
traditional without being traditional
themselves they want all of the benefits
that come with masculinity the
protection and all that other kind of
stuff without having to without having
to be the traditional woman uh uh
themselves they want all the masculinity
without any of the femininity and i'm
here to tell you man look man i'm not
giving you my masculinity unless unless
i see that femininity that's just all
there is to it i don't care who you are
so why don't you tell the people what
solutions you sell
i'll just give you a couple of uh quick
women's examples if a woman says hey i
haven't been in a relationship in two
years translation i've been [ __ ]
random guys for two years uh a woman
says hey we broke up well why'd you
break up well we grew apart translation
i was [ __ ] other guys on the side um
i fell out of love with him translation
i fell in love with somebody else um i
was raised in a strict christian home uh
translation i'm a [ __ ] uh uh
i used to be in i used to be an ugly
duckling i used to be fat translation
i'm an epic [ __ ] because now that i get
attention from guys i don't know how to
act there's so many things women women
tell us exactly who and what they are to
our faces every day every day
and men continue to get blindsided
because they do not know how to read
between the lines ergo womanies there's
one of these how to build a quality
woman from the ground up how to master
the game uh i've got all of my womany's
i've got all womany's volumes i've got
them in audio uh video format uh ebook
format and paper and paperback format
and i think
one of the best things that donovan does
is he date he breaks down dating shows
oh yeah yeah
and of course we can't put those on
youtube obviously so we put them on our
website sharpstream.com
and so people can go there and like see
in real time his reactions his his
predictions like and then what happens
like whether it's like what we did um
temptation island all four scenes oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah um
a little bit of too hot to handle oh
yeah yeah i love this line the ultimatum
like all these things it's really fun to
like you know because when he does the
breakdowns live it's on our on
sharpstream.com and it's like it's we
have chat in there and everything and
like it's it's a lot of fun
um so like if people prefer to not have
like an like a course type of thing but
they'd rather just see the stuff in real
time that's another way that they can uh
get educated and a lot of people a lot
of guys say oh these dating shows are
scripted and blah blah blah blah
it's dating show it's funny
when when people call dating shows
scripted that just proves that they they
don't have red pill awareness they just
don't have red pill awareness because
when you watch this stuff
you can you can clearly tell that these
things are absolutely true that that
that we talk that we talk about this is
why i'm able to so accurately predict so
many scenarios because i do have red
pill awareness yes there are elements
that are that are certainly quote
unquote scripted but
if if dating shows were scripted then
they would not have the outcomes that
they have that much i can tell you uh by
the way uh you can watch my dating show
breakdowns on sharpstream built by the
lovely and talented devon so devin built
sharpstream.com she built the mobile app
which you can download on the uh uh app
store and the google play store she
built both she built both apps from the
ground up so if anybody said well what
does devon bring to the table
sharpstream.com go to the app store
search sharp stream that's part of what
she brings to the table i'm a money
maker and not from
she's a money maker and she has nice
knockers
and and donovan is hilarious donald
could damn near do stand up
oh my god
i don't know
look people tell me that i'm a funny i
just don't see myself as that funny i
don't know i don't know oh please if you
ever did just stand up i'd fly out
oh my god
i would never do that listen stand up
comedians those are some ballsy
[ __ ] man that's a hard job
but you guys definitely should check out
his content the thing about donovan is
he like is so passionate and he puts his
like heart into everything he does and i
can tell he really cares
about the guys that he mentors and he
was also a big up with me he put me on
his channel early on and i really
appreciated it he was you know very
encouraging and was a very good mentor
so if you need a mentor and like
business or relationship donovan
definitely is the guy to get that done
that's exactly right that's exactly
right so why don't you tell the people
where they can find you
uh yeah uh
donovansharp.comsharpstream.com
uh
tsracademy.com if you want to know where
my youtube channel is just search
jonathan
you always forget the marketing stuff
see this is why see this is why she's
here i'm very dude i'm
i'm not good at a lot of things i'm only
good and the few things that i'm good at
i'm really good at everything else i'm
terrible at but yes we are running a
flash sale fourth of july go to
tsrtsr academy.com all of my courses
books everything are all 50 off uh
through july 4th um you can also find me
on twitch you can find me on twitter you
can find me on facebook uh you can find
me on uh what is the other tick tock and
also on instagram uh donovan sharp on
youtube
i said that one first yeah
youtube
when he's when he says
you gotta let me finish it's translation
i was just about to say that
like what was that
reminding me you could you could do a
mendy's course well well here's see
here's the thing now now here's the
thing i'm not gonna i'm not gonna sit
here and say well i was gonna say that
no i [ __ ] forgot to say it like i
would listen
listen i forgot to plug i forgot to plug
the sale it's not it doesn't make you a
beta male if you just don't know
something
and so
look if you have someone who reminds you
about the marketing stuff it does not
make you less of a man to say you know
what my bad i forgot let me go ahead and
mention that it is what it is man we
have too many we have too many want to
uh red pill super alphas you know i'm
not gonna do [ __ ] for her i'm not gonna
i'm right no man dude if you're wrong
just admit you're wrong because a real
man can just admit that he's wrong and
just move the [ __ ] on man [ __ ] all this
nonsense
okay um
so guys go check them out they are my
fav red pill couple don't forget to
subscribe to the channel for real like
this video on your way out if you've
watched two or more of my videos and you
don't subscribe we have beef okay
these people
and yeah go check out their content we
will talk to you next time bye thanks
guys